-Guys, it's time for "Tonight Show" Hashtags.
Here we go.
-♪ Hashtags ♪
♪ Hashtags ♪
-We do this thing every week where I send out a hashtag
and I ask you guys to respond to that topic.
This week I sent out the hashtag "Pet Costumes,"
and I asked you to tweet out your cutest,
funniest pet costumes.
Within minutes, it was a trending topic in the US,
so thank you for playing along.
Now I thought I'd share
some of my favorite pet costumes from you guys.
Here we go. This first one is from @sbrabston.
She shared a photo of the Blues Brothers.
Look at these guys. Yeah. Not bad.
[ Cheers and applause ]
They're really cute.
This one's from @aweis07.
She shared a photo of Snoopy with Charlie Brown.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Look at the baby. -Aww, look at Charlie Brown.
Cute little baby.
This one is from @NotPurfect-- -Ooh.
-"P-U-R." -Oh, like the cat.
-Oh, yeah. -[ Imitates purring ]
-@NotPurfect07. -I want it to be a cat photo.
-She shared a photo of a literal Chia Pet.
-Oh.
[ Applause ]
-Brilliant.
That's a great idea. -Yeah.
-This one is from @SayItDontSpayIt.
-Oh, wow. Okay.
-He shared a photo of a scene from the movie "It."
[ Laughter, applause ]
-Oh, my God. -Oh, my God.
-You know how long that would have taken
to put all that together?
-That's like a week and a half. -That's a day-and-a-half shoot.
-"Stay there, stay there. Stay, stay, stay, stay, stay."
-It's not even Halloween. -Yeah.
-Pretty great, though.
This one is from @krisflyau.
She shared a photo of her Boxer as a boxer.
-Aww! [ Applause ]
Meta.
This one's from @syd dumb.
They shared a photo of their breakfast.
[ Applause ]
I guess use the cone.
-He probably had surgeries, got spayed.
-This one's from @SUNshyzzle.
She shared a photo of a rare Beanie Baby.
Ooh. [ Applause ]
-Just use a tag. These are good ideas.
This one's from @NahTunaKerr.
-"NahTunaKerr." -NahTunaKerr.
NahTunaKerr?
-Not tuna... -Nah...
-"Nah, tuna care."
-Yeah. "Nah, tuna care." -Yeah.
-I guess so.
-Or maybe they care about tuna.
-"NahTuna-- NahTunaKerr."
[ Laughter ]
I know I'm missing something.
I just don't know what I'm missing.
They shared a photo of their favorite fruit.
Aww, that dog looks miserable.
[ Applause ]
[ Laughing ] That dog. That dog is so mad.
-Oh, my God.
What am I doing? What am I doing?
This last one is from @iceicecoldbrrr.
They shared a photo of their favorite Miley music video.
There you have it, "Wrecking Ball."
[ Applause ] [ Laughs ]
There you have it.
Those are "Tonight Show" hashtags.
To check out more of our favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags.